ALLEN ARCHULETA OR ATKINS EIGHT
WELL ORIGINS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG SALLY DODD THE RAZA
GALGIANI LASER GONZALEZ ROSE
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO HURTADO
JACKSON JONES EVA WIRE MELENDEZ
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCK.
AROUND NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROCK RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER
Y. CASKEY WIENER WILK. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE. WILL BE LED IMPAIR
THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR HILL
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LET IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BUT SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MYSTERIOUS HOW HE
WON. WE MUST TRUST THAT YOU ARE
NOT SITTING IDLY BY WATCHING
OUR SELF DESTRUCTION. YOU ARE
AT WORK THROUGH US IN EVERY
MOMENT. THE SAME DANCE OF
ELECTRONS AND EMBRACE OF
GRAVITY VIBRATING WITH LOVE
CREATING AND CREATING GRACE IN
THE VERY BEING OF OUR STRUGGLES
AND IMPERFECTIONS. IN EVERY
MOMENT THROUGH US YOU ARE
MENDING WHAT IS FROM THE DEPTHS
OF WHAT IS TRAGIC FOR MAGIC
MOMENTOUS OR MUNDANE. ARE EVERY
MOMENT IS A CHOICE. JOINT IN
HARMONY. ME BY WE ARE READY FOR
THIS DAY. THE OF A LOT OF OUR
HEART IS MEANT TO ENLIGHTEN
ROLLED SB FIVE BY YOU. WHEN I
LIVE. MAY NOT LOSE. HEY MAN.
YEAH. IT IS SO. ALL. MEMBERS
THERE ARE NO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE'RE
NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS MISSIONS
AND ASSIST. SO GROW. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I LIKE THE
COLOR REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE.
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN
THE PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE
ARE READY TO BEGIN THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAS ENDED.
BUT. MEMBERS BEFORE WE GET
STARTED- MADAM SECRETARY IS
GOING TO READ A MESSAGE TO US
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE PROCEED. NOT
FOR I AM DIRECTED TO INFORM
YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED ON AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN AND SENATE
BILL ONE NINETEEN AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HONORABLE
BODY TO CONCURRENT SAID
AMENDMENTS TO PARK SHE QUIRK OF
THE ASSEMBLY ABOUT THE BILL'S
ORDER TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILE. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE THE SERGEANTS
ARE HANDING IT OUT FOR YOU YOU
CAN LOOK AT THAT CENTER
MELINDA'S WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE
I THINK YOU AYE REYES UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IF I
MAY PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I'M MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW SB ARE NINETY THREE
FROM THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
AND TO BE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE.
IS THAT THIS NAY ART SENATE CAN
HAVE A VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT
THE MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR
STATE OF EMERGENCY. THANK YOU
SENATOR I WOULD LIKE TO STATE
THE REASONS FOR MY MOTION IF I
MAY IF YOU'RE READY FOR ME TO
PROCEED WITH THAT YOU MAY TALK
TO THE MOTION DIRECTLY YES OKAY
THANK YOU. AND MEMBERS I AM
ASKING FOR THIS RESOLUTION TO
BE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
NUMBER NUMBER REASONS ONE. AT
BECAUSE THE RESOLUTION WILL
RESTORE THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
INSTILLED WITHIN OUR
CONSTITUTION. OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY DAYS THAT OUR STATE HAS
BEEN IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
RELATED TO CODE IN OUR ROLES AS
LEGISLATORS HAVE BEEN GREATLY
DIMINISHED- THE GOVERNOR'S.
SPENDING AUTHORITY HAS
INCREASED WE HAD A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- THINGS THAT I
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEBATED IN THE LEGISLATURE. ARE
NOW I'M DONE SO BY EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND I AM FRUSTRATED WITH
THAT AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
ARE. SO I THINK TO ESSENTIALLY
WRIST ALL OUR ROLE IN THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY IS
APPROPRIATE AND THIS IS WHY. I
AM MAKING A MOTION. TO MOVE
ESSERE NINETY THREE FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR DEBATE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MELINDA'S CENTER
HERTZBERG. SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
SIR. SENATOR JONES. REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS CHAIR ASKS FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR THEY CAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO
BATES HI BEL. NO GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD NO BY ADAM. NO CHIANG.
DALLY I DODD. NOTE TO RAZA NO
GALGIANI NO GLAZER NO GONZALEZ.
NO GROWTH HI HERTZBERG. NO HILL
NO WAY SO. NO HURTADO NO
JACKSON NO JONES I LEYVA NO NO
MCGUIRE NO MELENDEZ. I MITCHELL
NO MONEY. NO MORE LOCK. HIGH
MORALE. MORALE. FIVE NIELSEN I
PAN NO PORTANTINO NO ROTH. NO
RUBIO. NO SKINNER. NO STERN.
NUMBER OF NO WAY CASKEY NO
WIENER. NO WILK HI. THE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG
STERN. THANK YOU THE MOTION
FAILS MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE THAT YOU ALL HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU LOOKS LIKE THIS. SENATOR
MITCHELL ARE YOU READY. THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT- GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN IS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRADE BILL. JUST TO CLARIFY
THIS BILL IS IDENTICAL TO A. B.
EIGHTY EIGHT PASSED ON THIS
FLOOR LATE JUNE BUT SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE BY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
WHICH IS REQUIRED THAT WE TAKE
THIS BILL UP AGAIN. TO CLARIFY
IN MINUTES TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY DO THE FOLLOWING. THEY
REMOVE STATEWIDE JUDICIAL
AUTHORITY TO OFFER MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION. IT REMOVES CHANGES
TO ELDER PAROLE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA. AND PROVIDES
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATION THAT
EXPLICITLY. EXEMPTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT COURSES IN PRO.
FROM THE DAY THE BOX PROVISION
BESIDE THESE CHANGES THIS BILL
INCLUDES THE SAME CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORMS IN THAT WERE
CONTAINED IN AB EIGHTY EIGHT ON
THAT REFLECT THE GOVERNOR
LEGISLATURE'S DATA AND EVIDENCE
BASED PROPOSALS FOR REDUCING
OUR STATE THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR PRISON BUDGET PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND SHE EVEN OUR
OVERALL BUT TO SAVE. THE BILL
PROVIDES BEST SPECIFICITY ON
THE PLAN TO CLOSE THE STATE
OWNED AND OPERATED PRISON BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE
SECOND BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IN
DETERMINING WHICH FACILITIES TO
CLOSE THIS BILL REQUIRES
FACTORS SUCH AS OPERATIONAL
COSTS FACILITY CONDITION AND
SYSTEM WIDE OPERATIONAL NEEDS
TO BE WEIGHED HEAVILY. THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES REFORMS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM FOR EXAMPLE IT BANS
THE BOX ON MOST COLLEGE
APPLICATION ADMISSION
APPLICATIONS AND UPDATES THE
STATE'S PAROLE SYSTEM BY
CREATING INCENTIVES LIKE EARNED
EARLY DISCHARGE IN PLACE IN THE
MAXIMUM. ON PAROLE TERMS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL BEFORE WE
GO TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
IT'S ONE REMIND MEMBERS TO KEEP
YOUR MOUTH ON IT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE COVERING YOUR
NOSE. AS WELL EVERY ONCE IN A
GREAT JOB RIGHT NOW BUT
SOMETIMES AS WE GET INTO
SESSION THEY FALL DOWN BUT
PLEASE REMEMBER TO KEEP THEM
OVER YOUR ENTIRE FACE. FIRST UP
IS SENATOR NELSON. BETTER LATE
GERMAN CENTER I REQUEST A NO
VOTE THESE ARE SUBSTANTIVE.
AMENDMENTS AND OF OR THE OF A
LOT MORE EXPLORATION THEN THE
CURSORY ONE WE'RE GETTING HERE.
ANOTHER THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN. IN A FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MEMBERSHIP CHAIR YOU MAY CLOSE
FRIEND I BOTH THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. I ACTIONS I
BASS. NO BELL HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DODD. I DURAZO HI
GALGIANI. GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HI HELLO
AYE HUESO AYE TADO. HURTADO NO
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE HI MULLIN. NO MITCHELL
HI MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK. NO
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN.
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER HI STERN
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GALGIANI STERN. FIVE TWENTY SIX
NEWS TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
SENATOR MITCHELL IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE NINETEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
EMPLOYMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY
DOES THE BUDGET. SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ON COLLEAGUES YOU MAY
RECALL THE BUDGET AX SPECIFIED
SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION SPECIAL FUNDS
ASSOCIATED WITH REDUCTIONS IN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION. THIS
BILL PROVIDES OF LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION MAKES CONFORMING
STATUTORY CHANGES THE END.
NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED. THESE
AGREEMENTS INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING BARGAINING UNITS
BARGAINING UNIT TO REPRESENTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES IN
HERE SUSAN STATE EMPLOYMENT
BARGAIN UNITS FIVE REPRESENTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN. AND SEVEN YEAR BUT
CALIFORNIA STATE WHY LONG
ASSOCIATE. CAN YOU EIGHT
REPRESENTED BY CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY. BARKING
UNIT NINE REPRESENTED BY THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
BARGAINING UNIT TEN REPRESENT
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS
BARGAINING UNIT TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN REPRESENTED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION. ENGINEERS
BARGAIN SIXTEEN BY THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS BRINGING IN EIGHTEEN
REPRESENT BUT IN CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS AND
BARGAINING UNIT NINETEEN
REPRESENTED BY THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ALSO KNOWN
AS ASKS ME. BILLS THE SPINS THE
EMPLOYEE MY CONTRIBUTION TO PRE
FUND OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND OR TWO ONE THREE TWO FOR
THESE BARGAINING UNIT WHILE
MAINTAINING THE STATE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS AT SPECIFIED. THE
BILL ALSO APPROPRIATE THREE
POINT ONE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND TWO POINT SEVEN EIGHT
MILLION IN OTHER. THEM TO
PROVIDE OF THESE M. ALL USE I
ASKED FOR AND I. HE MET CENTER
MITCHELL MEMBER ANY TO. AND
DEBATE. YES CENTER NIELSEN. A
NO VOTE AGAIN THE BILL AS IT
WILL NOW BE BEFORE US AND WE'VE
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO READ IT
WE'VE HEARD THE SUMMARY THAT IT
IS VERY SUBSTANTIVE SOME OF
THESE MO USER WORTHY OF SUPPORT
I WOULD ARGUE. BUT SOME ARE
NOT. IN A STANDARD WAY WE LOVE
THEM ALL TOGETHER AND YOU TAKE
THE GOOD BAD AND THE UGLY AND-
AND HAVE TO EAT IT BUT THERE
ARE PROVISIONS IN HERE OF SOME
SIGNIFICANCE THUS I WOULD URGE
AND OVER. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
HEARING NONE SENATE MITCHELL
PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
A PRESIDENTIAL TO CLARIFY THAT
THE BILL HAS BEEN IN PRINT IT
WAS AMENDED JULY TWENTY
SEVENTH. ARE IT THIS WAS HER.
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE LAST WEEK.
OUR AND IN TYPICAL TRAILER BILL
FASHION ON THERE'S NOT A
QUESTION ABOUT YOUR MAIN THIS
THESE ARE ALL BARGAINING UNITS-
AND IT REFLECTS ALL THE AMMO
USE THAT RENEGOTIATING FOR
THOSE REASONS I ASKED FOR AND I
DON'T. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
OR HI ATKINS HI PLEASE. BELL
FIVE FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE
ITEM HI CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD.
I DORADO HI GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I HELLO HI HUESO. HI
FOR TADO FIVE JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL. MITCHELL I MONNING
I MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. NO HAN AYE PORTANTINO
HI ROSS I RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN. NUMBER HI Y. CASKEY HI
WIENER. I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
BATES. NO FOR JUST. NO STERN.
SIZE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING BACK TO MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ US
ANOTHER MESSAGE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
DIRECTED. TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AND THEN AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AND IS AS AMENDED.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOUR
AND SENATE BILL FOUR TWENTY
THREE AND RESPECTFUL REQUESTS
YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENT SAID AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY. ABOVE THE BILL'S.
ORDER TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILE. THANK YOU MA'AM SIX
MEMBER WERE MOVING BACK TO
MOTION AND RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR JULY TWENTY SEVENTH THROUGH
JULY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
WILL BE PERU APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN THE FOLLOWING BILL
WILL BE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE SB FOUR TWENTY THREE.
SENATOR DORADO FOR A PURPOSE TO
RISE. MADAM CHAIR I RISE TO
PULL ITEM FORTY ONE AB TWO FOUR
SEVEN ONE MAIENSCHEIN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO THE DESK WILL NOTE
MEMBERS ANYTHING ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. VERY
GOOD SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE SECOND READ FILE MA'AM.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL.
465-904-1920. 727-401-2420 SIX
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE AS BILL
TWENTY FORTY WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THREE AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY THE SECOND RING
FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SENATOR WILL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF- LILA GARCIA
BROWER IS THE CHIEF OF THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT. PARTY THIS
APPOINTMENT MISS GARCIA BROWER
WAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MAIN IS CORPORATION TRUST FUND
CHOOSE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY FIRST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL. A
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
ALSO. YES I RISE TO SUPPORT
THIS- APPOINTMENT OF FROM OUR
SEE BROWER I KNOWN HER FOR
YEARS IT WAS REALLY GREAT HER
WORK THAT SHE DID WITH
EMPLOYERS AND LABOR TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN
BUSINESSES IT WAS SHE WORKED
FOR A WATCHDOG ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKED TO ELIMINATE
ILLEGAL UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY. HE WORKED FOR FAIR
BUSINESS COMPETITION I'M VERY
PROUD OF ALL OF HER WORK AND I
RISE TO SUPPORT HER
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
DORADO MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE YES
SENATOR BATES. I RELUCTANTLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS OF
APPOINTMENT CONFIRMATION WHEN I
INTERVIEWED- THE CANDIDATE AND
SPOKE TO HER ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT OF AB FIVE IN THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE TO THAT.
ASKING IF THERE WAS GOING TO BE
SOME GUIDANCE- BECAUSE OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESS SITE THEN
ENTREPRENEURS WHO ARE REALLY
ARE NIFTY CANTLEY FINANCIALLY
AT RISK. BECAUSE OF THAT
ENFORCEMENT ORDER WHAT SORT OF
GUIDANCE WOULD BE GIVEN ON TO
HELP THEM NAVIGATE WHAT IS TO
BE IN A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION. AND ON A WAS PRETTY
CAVALIERLY ANSWER THEY'LL JUST
HAVE TO GET AN ATTORNEY I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A CORRECT ANSWER. PEOPLE
THAT ARE PUT IN THESE POSITIONS
OF EXTREME IMPORTANCE TO THE
ECONOMY OF THE SUN. STATE NEED
TO HAVE A LITTLE BROADER VIEW
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT THERE
IN THE REAL WORLD SO I ARE
RECOMMENDED NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BELL I FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I CHIANG.
DALY DODD FIVE DORADO HI
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I HELLO
HI HUESO. HI TADO HI JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL BY
MORNING HI MORE LOCK AROUND.
AROUND NO NIELSEN NO PAN. HI
PORTANTINO HI RALPH. HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER RIGHT
I WAY CASPI AYE WIENER HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST. NO CHIANG. DALLY.
JONES MORE LOCK. STERN WILK.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NO SIX THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR
WILL MEMBERS ARE PERCENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF SENATOR IS
A DOOR HALL TO AGRICULTURE
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD CENTER
WITH MANY PERSON BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY PRIOR
TO HIS APPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE WAS
APPROVED THE RULE EIGHTY ON THE
FIRST OF JULY I RESPECTFULLY
STATUS FOR IN. THANK YOU CENTER
WILK MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. BETTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. NO WELL I FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD. CUT BY A- I
CHIANG. HI DOLLY HI DODD. I
DORADO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
HI HILL. HI WITH SO HI HURTADO
HI JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
I MONNING I MORE LOCK. AROUND.
NO NIELSEN. CAN I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH. I RUBIO. HI SCHOOL. HI
STERN. NUMBER HI WHAT CASKEY I
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD I.
MORE LOCK. NIELSEN STERN. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS SIXTY
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FILE I NUMBER SIXTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF RALPH FLIGHT
STONE TO AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD MISTER
LIGHTSTONE IS AN ATTORNEY AND
PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE APPEALS
BOARD IN SEVERAL POSITIONS AT
THE LABOR WORK ELEMENT AGENCY
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE COME ON
THE FIRST OF AND- ASK NIGHT OF.
THE USER WILL MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARE TO ATTEND. I ATKINS
I BATES. BELL HI FORGES I
BRADFORD HI CAN I ADAM HI
CHIANG I DALY. HI DON. I TO
RESUME. HI GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG I HILL HI WITH SO. I
FOR TIGHTENING. HI JACK TAX. HI
JONES NO LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE. HI
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I MORE LOCK. AROUND NO
NIELSEN. PAM I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN. NUMBER I WHAT CASTING HI
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WICKS MORE
LOCK. NIELSEN RUBIO. I STERN.
EYES THIRTY THREE KNOWS THREE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
GREGORY- HER KEITH THE MILLS
AND PEER STERN TO THE LOTTERY
COMMISSION MR A HERNIA SHERATON
CORNER FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY MISS
MILLS IS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MR STERN A
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AT IN
EXCEPTION CORPORATION ALL THREE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE FIRST OF
JULY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM THANK YOU SENATOR WILK
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE-
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
FIVE BATES. BELL FIVE GORGEOUS
I BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW. I
CHIANG. VALLEY. DELHI I DON. HI
TORONTO. GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI HUESO HI
TADO FIVE JACKSON. I JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL I MONNING HI MORE LOCK
WELL. MORRELL NO NEED. PAN I
PORTANTINO I BROUGHT. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. I'M BURKE I Y.
CASKEY I WIENER. I WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PLEASE CHIANG. TORONTO I JONES.
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. NIELSEN
STERN. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS TO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS I'M JUST GOING TO
REMIND YOU ABOUT YOUR MASK
ABOUT ONE PERSON WHERE THEIR
MASK ON THEIR CHEN IT DOESN'T
DO US ANY GOOD IF IT'S ON YOUR
CHANCE OF GOING PULLED UP OVER
YOUR NOSE FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION IN
MERION SPEARMAN AS A SO. TO AT
THE DO. OF A DAY INSTITUTIONS
AT CDC ARE. MISTER SPEARMAN HAS
SPENT HIS ENTIRE THIRTY THREE
YEAR CAREER AT THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. MOST RECENTLY
SERVING AS THE WARDEN OF HIGH
DESERT. STATE PRISON FOR THREE
YEARS HE WAS IN THE CENTER
COMMITTEE ON THE FIRST OF JULY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WILK
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES I TELL HI GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM. I
CHIANG HI DOLLY I DONT. HI
DORADO HI GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER
HI IS ALL THIS. I GROW. I
HERTZBERG I HELLO HI WITH SO. I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES HI LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. HI
MITCHELL. HI MONEY HI MORE LOCK
I RURAL. I NIELSEN. I PAN I
PORTANTINO HI ROSS. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN. NUMBER
RIGHT HI WHAT CASKEY. I WIENER.
HI WILK. HI PAGE THIRTY NINE
NEWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED.
OKAY MEMBERS ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN IT'S
THIRTY NINE I KNOWS ZERO ANY
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED THAT
WILL. DO OUR APPOINTMENTS FOR
THE DAY IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. SENATE PRESIDENT
AT SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK TODAY- WE WILL
RECESS UNTIL- OUR- WORK IS
CONCLUDED TODAY AND RECONVENE
AS IN SESSION ON THURSDAY
AUGUST SIXTH AT NINE AM THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL RECESS UNTIL ALL OF.
BUSINESS SEE UP AS- BEING ON
THIRD AT NINETY HAVE A DAY EVER.